(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] If you're like most people,
you've probably felt like
our political climate
is hostile to freethinkers,
those who don't
automatically accept the
woke opinion of the day.
As someone who has gone
from woke to awake,
I'm here to tell you that it
hasn't always been this way.
In fact, the guiding philosophy
of the U.S. Constitution
is Classical Liberalism,
but most people have
no idea what it truly means.
It's time to fix that.
Classical Liberalism posits
that the government's
top priority is protecting
individual rights,
including the right to own what we earn
and express what we
believe, so that society
can progress towards
tolerance and justice for all.
Freedom and liberty are
of the highest order,
and the light touch of
government is allowed
when absolutely necessary.
As you've likely noticed,
today's liberals have strayed
from this ideal.
Modern Progressives take
pride in segregating Americans
into identity groups, like
Black, White, Gay or Straight,
abandoning the profoundly
simple, yet incredibly important
idea that all men are created equal.
The Progressive worldview is
tempting, because it's safe.
As long as you accept your
privilege or your victimhood
status, you are guaranteed
social acceptance.
This outlook squashes voices
who challenge the norm
and prevents us from achieving
the truly liberal goals
our founders imagined.
Free thinking is risky,
there isn't a road map that
delivers you to a set destination,
and there's no political
party or identity group
for you to call home.
But I would say that
charting your own course
is a risk worth taking.
Think for yourself, and thank me later.